[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Полтавщина
Решетилівка]
Традиційне народне мистецтво
люди думають повинно бути  дешево, повинно бути просто.
І ніхто не задумується,
скільки на це витрачається часу, сили, терпіння...
Скільки для цього потрібно вчитися.
Я для себе обрала килимарство.
Цим шляхом  іду вже понад двадцять років.
[Ольга Пілюгіна
майстриня килимарства]
Мене вчила ткати моя старша сестра,
а вона вчилась ткати у художньому училищі.
Я гралася  у килимарських майстернях:
то ниточками, то ткала, то вишивала.
Коли мені було десь дванадцять років,
сестра сказала: «Досить гратися,
давай серйозно підіймемо до цього питання».
Вона мені показала, що якою рукою робиться,
техніки показала і вже на великих килимах ми сідали поруч.
Спочатку й плакала, бо вона відмірить,
скільки потрібно за день зробити.
Вона свою роботу зробила і пішла,
а мені треба бігом-бігом до цієї лінії,
адже завтра буде ще більше завдання.
Тато з мамою працювали у художньому училищі.
Мама вишивку викладала, а тато...
та вони мабуть все викладали.
Їх запросили із Москви
як двох спеціалістів, які знають все.
Взагалі у родині Пілюгіних дуже багато художників — чотирнадцять.
[Наталія Пілюгіна
майстриня вишивки]
Нас у батьків четверо. І всі – художники, всі навчалися у Московському художньому училищі.
Наші діти теж всі художники.
Тато із Запорізької області, мама із Тамбовської.
Навчалися у Москві.
Тато чув про Решетилівку
і виконував тут свою дипломну роботу.
Йому хотілося сюди приїхати.
Тому, коли приїхали сюди, товирішили залишитися.
Я вже тут народилась.
Це двостороннє гладке ручне ткатство.
Тобто воно однакове з двох сторін.
Тут немає жодного вузлика, нитки не зв'язуються між собою.
Таке от гніздо з дітками. Тато, мама.
Таке дерево життя.
Спочатку потрібно намалювати ескіз.
Потім – робочий малюнок у натуральну величину.
Тобто робочий малюнок це...
в принципі, та сама робота, тільки на папері і гуашшю.
От, підкладається вона ззаду.
І потрібно це все повторити потім нитками.
Кожен шматочок можна розглядати,
там багато відтінків, понад 100 відтінків робота може мати.
Тато фарбує нитки. Дістає ті відтінки, які мені потрібно.
Там щось чорне вариться,
він  дістав: «Таке?» — «Таке!»
Тут кожна рука виконує свою роботу.
Тобто права рука вибирає задні нитки,
ліва робить просту роботу — підтримує передні нитки.
Я вже на нитки не дивлюся, я дивлюся лише на малюнок.
Гребінка, вона...
ущільнює.
Коли залишаються кінчики,
їх потім, коли натчеш вище, можна буде обрізати.
Вони вже не розпускаються під власною вагою ниток.
Це більш вільне ткацтво,
така техніка кругляння.
Коли можна вище, нижче ткати.
Раніше тут була фабрика всесоюзного значення,
сюди приїжджали художники з усього Радянського Союзу.
Життя килимарства вирувало.
Зараз фабрики немає.
Є приватний підприємець, який зібрав килимарниць.
Проте він ніякого відношення до творчості немає –
вони роблять сувенірну продукцію.
[Решетилівка
Майстерня художніх промислів]
Решетилівка дійсно відома своїми народними промислами,
[Сергій Колінченко
директор Решетилівської майтерні]
а народні промисли були сконцентровані в решетилівській фабриці.
Ми на базі фабрики створили майстерню.
В нас працює вже 17 людей,
але ми додали ще й комп'ютерну техніку.
Те надбання, яке було в Решетилівці,
ми зробимо в електронному вигляді.
Щоб, як кажуть, навіки було.
Так снують на Полтавщині лише в Решетилівці.
Це особливе снування верстата.
Наприклад, моя робота «Коляда».
Її вже багато хто використовує
і для листівок, і повторюють.
Я вже бачила і розпис на склі, і батик.
Президент України привітав всіх цією роботою,
не знаючи, що це моя робота.
То мій автопортрет.
Тче і дивиться на світ через нитки основи
і сама вплітається туди.
Мої праці — не повтор народних килимів,
а вже авторські твори.
Намагаюсь рухатись вперед,
розвивати килимарство.
Навчаю діток маленьких.
Від 4-х років.
Ще не ткацтву, поки ще вони малюють.
Потрібно їм основи дати.
Поняття про орнамент.
Якось потрібно вийти нам на ткацтво.
Щоб виткати всі свої ідеї
потрібно дуже багато часу.
На це часу немає.
Живописців і так дуже багато.
А от хто б займався килимарством, то їх дуже мало.
[Автор проєкту:
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори:
Дмитро Охріменко, Павло Пашко]
[Продюсерка:
Наталка Панченко]
[Режисер:
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка:
Анна Воробйова]
[Субтитрувальник:
Влад Цовма]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]